[Music]
what it do everyone my name is ross
panetta chef and owner of five kitchen
and this is celebrity recipe royale
today we'll be taking fried rice recipes
from
jenny from blackpink rich brian david
chang
and the fried rice god himself uncle
roger now which celebrity has the best
fried rice
let's find out first up we have jenny
from blackpink's recipe for the popular
korean dish kimchi fried rice
we're going to start off by thinly
sliced and some scallions we're going to
be using both the greens and the white
so no waste
next up we're going to cut up some thick
slices of pork belly and put that to the
side
now we're going to mix up some kimchi
make sure you wear a glove so you don't
get no kimchi juice in your eye
in a pan we're going to saute our pork
belly until it gets a little bit of
color
once that's done you're going to throw
in your kimchi a little bit of scallion
and cook that out we're going to add our
rice
fry it up for a bit season it with salt
and pepper and then we're going to add
some seasoned gochujang
before serving we're going to finish it
up with some fresh scallion and there
you have it jenny's kimchi fried rice
visually i am stimulated see the
scallions
all spicy now let's give this a try
it's got like a little bit of a kick to
it it's mild it's definitely not too
overpowering the meat very different
than what i'm used to for fried rice
but it tastes good this tastes okay but
this might not be my pick
it's good i like it it still kind of has
that like korean flavor
next up in the ring is rich brian with
his take on the indonesian national dish
nasi goreng in a saute pan we're going
to throw in some canola oil
a couple tablespoons of candle nut spice
mix and some chopped garlic we're going
to cook out the canned nut spice mix
until it gets fragrant
then we're going to add in our chopped
chicken pieces we're going to make a
well in the center scramble an egg
and cook it out to that we're going to
add some leftover rice throw in some
seasoning some white pepper
some turmeric some salt and tea cap
mayonnaise which is some sweet soy
we're going to fry it up until it gets
nice and colorful to that we're going to
add some fresh chopped scallion
if it ain't cracking enough already rich
bryant tops it off with a nicely fried
egg
i think this was a contender there you
have it rich brian's snazzy goring
smells good visually it looks promising
it kind of smells like
more like southeast asian
oh yeah it's a flavor explosion in my
mouth i taste the curry
there's a kick of spice it's kind of
lacking salt i wish there's a little
more salt in here
not bad definitely not bad i love it a
lot of mixture of spices like different
flavors
i don't really taste much like sweet or
salty it's kind of like a spice that
dominates it
all right sean next up we have david
chang's spin on chinese fried rice
we're going to start off by thinly
slicing some scallions and putting that
to the side
now we're going to roughly chop an onion
and also put that to the side
we're going to mix up some garlic and
now we're gonna chop up our bacon into
lardons
we're gonna fry out the bacon for about
10 to 15 minutes until it gets nice and
crispy
in the same bacon fat we're gonna saute
our onions and peas
once the onions get a little bit of
color we're gonna mix it up with our
bacon
in a clean pan we're gonna throw in a
little bit of oil our leftover rice
we're gonna make a well in the middle
add in two eggs some scallion
and we're gonna fry that up all together
once the rice is nicely fried
we're gonna throw in our peas onions and
bacon mixture and mix it up
we're gonna season it with some soy
sauce some fish sauce a couple drops of
lime juice
if you didn't know now you know david
chang's bacon fried rice
ooh okay looks pretty simple in a good
way i love bacon
bacon and anything is good this is like
maybe an american version
of a fried rice yeah i like this a lot
most of the flavors just from the oil
and the pepper
this one also is very very flavorful
very sparing on the eggs i wish there's
more
but a lot of peas whoever made this
loves peas i would say this probably has
the most smaller one i'm used to which
is like a chinese taiwanese version of
fried rice i feel like
this is a little more upscale on the
fried rice
and now everyone's favorite uncle uncle
roger with his recipe
for egg fried rice we're gonna start off
by scrambling one egg and one yolk in a
bowl with chopsticks
next up we're gonna thinly slice some
shallot we're gonna mince up some garlic
make sure you crush it thinly slice some
long red chili
and set that to the side in a hot wok
we're gonna throw in a couple
tablespoons of oil
our shallot and our egg you want to fry
the egg until it gets nice and fluffy
once the egg is nice and fluffy you're
going to throw in your leftover highness
chicken rice we're going to fry that up
until it gets nice and happy
uncle roger uses a little bit of pepper
and soy sauce and now we add uncle
roger's most
important ingredient msg we're gonna fry
that up until it gets nice and delicious
we're gonna throw in some freshly sliced
scallions
our long red chilies and there you have
it uncle rogers egg fried rice
uncle roger please don't roast me
visually
not so satisfying i see a red chili it
smells good
there's a flavor in here that i'm not
too fond of
damn it's actually tasted pretty good
there's definitely like some type of
fish thing going on here
this is just not it it's very mushy just
because it's very monotonous in texture
i'm tasting a lot of garlic and ginger
but it's not overwhelming i think it's
done just right
flavor profile summed up simple spicy
fishy
delicious so which one of these
celebrities is gonna take the fried rice
championship belt
let's find out i would say my favorite
one would be number one
because that has the most flavor of all
of them and actually had like a good
salt level
okay not surprising okay my favorite has
got to be
number three i think it's simple i think
it really epitomizes what fried rice is
all about which is not a lot of
ingredients
but a lot of flavor david chang all
right there we go
i really like the third one i like the
bacon in there i like the peas i like
the flavor
i don't really know who that is but that
tasted really good
about to hit up momofuku because today
david chang
is the champion so what recipes you want
us to battle out next
leave a comment below
you